smoke disappears into the sky after yet
another night of destruction in towns
around the capital kiev
it's from places like this the russian
military commanders say they will
withdraw from
part of an agreement made with ukraine
during talks in turkey on tuesday
this ukrainian commander says some
russians are withdrawing
there are some signs they are
maneuvering there are signs of
withdrawal but the situation is unclear
because we cannot trust them so we will
observe the russian soldier never just
withdraws they steal and loot and we
have evidence of that happening
these people have fled their homes and
have come to bravery town hall to
register as evacuees
they welcomed the russian withdrawal
announcement and hoped to return home
but they have no idea whether home
survived the missiles rockets and
artillery shells
we will definitely go home and rebuild
our city because it's our home
definitely it's very painful to be in a
strange place with strangers i really
just want to go home
the russian withdrawal plan has been met
with skepticism as russian shelling
continues and scenes like this occur
every day this warehouse was hit in the
early hours of wednesday morning it's
actually the third time the warehouse
has been hit by shelling now president
vladimir zelinsky welcomes the russian
moves he says that they're positive but
he also says they don't drown out the
sound of the shelling imran khan al
jazeera on the outskirts of bravery
well russia's defense ministry insists
its new focus in ukraine is the eastern
donbass region hashem alberta from
moscow
on the military front the russian army
is saying that it has achieved its goals
in the kiev region and chernigov and
that its troops are now regrouping with
the focus shifting towards liberating
the donbass that's where you have the
two eastern provinces of lagansk and
doniask and it seems that we're likely
to see further emphasis on the doneesk
where the army has been saying that it
controls 50 percent of their territory
and that they are continuing in their
push to further expand their control on
the diplomatic front uh foreign many
south foreign affairs sergey lavrov said
that there are signs of progress in the
talks with the ukrainians and that the
russians
have received commitment from the
ukrainians
about ukraine not joining nato not
acquiring weapons of mass destruction
and not allowing any
foreign military bases to be built in
ukraine in the future and that the
ukrainians understand that
crimea and the donbas
are finalized are closed an indication
that the russians are not going to offer
any compromise as far as those two
issues are concerned we have to remind
our viewers that since the start of the
military operation the russians have
been insisting that the ukrainians have
to recognize crimea as russian and they
have to recognize
lugansk
and
dhonies as independent states